and tonight the southpaw tyler anderson
and he's going to face tim anderson
swing in a miss to start off the night
for
tyler anderson
strikes out temp
hit down the right field line in the air
long run for polanco he's there in fair
territory makes a little leap as he
makes the catch good play by polanco and
the pirates retire the white sox in
order in the first well lucas giolito
last august 25th we know about the
no-hitter and 13 strikeouts overall 386
era but three and two
colts strike three change up inside
corner
and one down
great change up from giolito and two
down in this first inning there we go
hayes at first two outs the pitch hooked
down the ground right to abreu he'll
step on first jacob stallings will lead
it off in the bottom of the second
high fastball busts him above the strike
zone
third strikeout for lucas that fastball
looks 105 once he starts throwing those
chain ups you know oh two polanco takes
a fastball back-to-back case for giolito
here in the second two down
and to center
goodwin
will play it
off the grass the pirates have a hit
bottom two nothing nothing
and they've got them picked off can you
believe it
phillip evans
took one step towards second gia ledo
fired a pick off toss and evans was out
by a mile at first and that is it
for the pirates in the second two outs
and back to the top for adam frazier
and this ball lined to right hooking and
it is gone out goes freighter
that 3-2 pitch he continued to battle
he goes deep
and it's one-nothing pittsburgh the 10th
pitch
of the at-bat
right down the middle
his third
change up
right there that was extraordinary it
really was again the change up was his
go-to pitch
stayed on it after seeing a 97 mile per
hour fastball at the top of the zone and
then being able to have the decency and
again the patience to be able to stay
back and hit that change up fourth
inning coming up tyler anderson will
work with the lead
swing and a miss and montana down on
strikes yes on that right side versus
lefty striking out at 36 of the time
past the pitcher there is a little
bobble by frazier but plenty of time to
pick it up and throw out a brayu
[Applause]
in on him roll to newman
and tyler anderson
continues his role here into the fifth
inning leori garcia will start off the
frame against tyler anderson
garcia pops up the first pitch
and the efficient tyler anderson gets
the first out in the fifth
how about the efficiency we're seeing
here that's 50 pitches total
here we go
getting the dugout wow
i count five pitches to get those three
outs tyler anderson is cruising along
right now adam frazier is going to lead
it off for the pirates outside and
fraser works to walk ryan reynolds over
two he's struck out and fouled out the
pitch swinging the line drive up the
middle base hit good read by frazier
he'll touch third and come on home
here's goodwin's throw it's to the plate
safe
frazier's in there
on the hit by reynolds and the pirates
lead two to nothing awesome job not
waiting around much at all for brian
reynolds jumping on the first pitch he
saw out over the plate
getting that line drive but adam frazier
froze has it just a little bit then it
was hauling around third base
brian goodwin came up with a strong
throw right on the bunny but adam frazer
was able to slide in under the tag
here it is
swinging a fly ball well hit to left
vaughn on the warning track makes a
running grab what a play by andrew
vaughn he just saved a run
and geolito does get through six we have
hit the seventh inning here's abreu the
2-1
round ball this time he can't get it and
that's a base hit for abreu
two and two
and it's a change up that was high and
garcia strokes it to center off the
bobble from reynolds it's abreu to third
and now the sox have two one with two
out in the seventh inning so yazzle hit
right handed against the lefty anderson
grandahl high drive deep center reynolds
back at the fence it is gone
white sox lead three to two
yes monty grand all a pitch hit
three-run shot
wow
boy welcome to the game yasmani what
have you been waiting for
one pitch three runs for the white sox
timing is everything maybe his biggest
hit of the year pirates will play from
behind for the first time tonight they
trail the white sox three to two oh and
that's a
rough pokemon drive yeah
that went out a lot faster and it came
in
and that snakes through
first and second
crochet to face newman back to back base
hits off the hard throwing lefty
gets it down a good one
on the move oh pass first this is going
to tie the game
how about that the first pitch he wasn't
bunny so it left a little indecision on
mankato of whether or not he was bunny
even though he stayed playing in and
then
when he laid the bun down it was a great
bun
one killed it right down to third base
line it was going to be a tough play
anyway
but again it's just that great hustle
and continue to put pressure on the
defense still nobody out second and
third tie game pinch hitter eric
gonzalez announced
and that's through
a pinch hit single for gonzalez cora
waving home newman he will score gonzo
into second
he is safe and the pirates take the lead
back
that high breaking ball
[Applause]
gonzo hits it
through that hole
shakes his hands right away knows he's
got at least one run in probably gonna
be two
five three pirates the pitch swinging a
hard ground ball through base hit for
brian reynolds
gonzalez trucks him to score
and an rbi single for reynolds makes it
six to three pirates
here we go ninth inning and the pirates
leading the white sox six to three and
richard rodriguez trusted with that lead
here in the night fly ball i think the
answer is yes david bednar will get his
first big league win as we raise the
jolly roger a comeback victory for the
bucks
over the white sox richard rodriguez
saves it
what a feel-good win this was that's one
of the better wins that they've had this
year that he loved every part of it